[Musique]
c'était le 15 avril 2019 on a tous gardé
en mémoire l'image de la flèche en feu
qui s'est écroulé le chef de l'état
était ce matin sur place l'objectif
c'est donc 2024 une date qui enjambe la
prochaine présidentielle
mais la visite du jour permet aussi au
président de quitter quelques instants
la crise sanitaire
chacune et chacun se remémore
aujourd'hui là où nous en étions il ya
deux ans l'émotion qui était la nôtre et
d'émotion les deux de tous les tous les
catholiques présents et de france
entière de toutes les parisiennes et où
les parisiens tous les français et les
françaises et je crois qu'on voit ici
combien en deux ans un travail immense
était accomplie l'architecte
je lui ai déjà expliqué plusieurs fois
et je leur fais de manière claire qu'il
ferme sa gueule et que nous avançons en
sagesse on a une proposition qui est
notamment de reprendre des parkings
souterrains sous la cathédrale qui nous
permettraient ça ce serait absolument
remarquable de faire un accès par la
scène on pourrait rentrer aussi par la
scène dans ce site est ensuite remonté
en surface pour aller à la cathédrale
et puis végétalisée aussi beaucoup
j'avais dix architectes taisez vous
faisons les choses calmement et le
moment venu nous dirons ce que nous
voulons sinon nous allons concentrer
balle a alors à la cinquième fois j'ai
dit de lui leur est le fait de fermer sa
gueule voilà permettez-moi d'abord de
vous remercier pour les très nombreux
témoignages de soutien qui me sont
venues de tous les bancs de cette
assemblée
croyez bien que j'en ai été profondément
touché ça a été quand même une année
extrêmement dur avec adapté des
faillites en cascade
je rappelle juste des chaînes comme
andré naf naf très maman la halle
camaïeu le magasin historique de tati
qui a fermé ses portes il ya quelques
mois comme disent les gens on sait pas
quelle sauce on va être mangé cette
manière de faire avec mais j'ai
l'impression depuis un an de jouer à man
u a dit vous savez value a dit pas plus
de 6 à table bon ben voilà donc cette
manière de faire oui je n'y consent plus
je vous annonce ce matin qu'on a décidé
de maintenir les règles de l'activité
partielle tout au long du mois de mai
c'est des règles qui sont très
protectrices pour les salariés et pour
les entreprises
donc on est vraiment très attentif
à ne pas retirer trop vite ces aides au
mois de mai fais ce qu'il te plaît faut
y avoir du beach volley en extérieur on
ouvre tout il faut avoir un livre tout
non on ouvre d'or
j'ai bien dit dehors dehors dehors
dehors dehors dehors du cas du karaoké
en extérieur du beach volley on
l'extérieur il faut et moi je serai là
pour organiser des pots de départ
d'emmanuel maquereau en extérieur au
siège annonçant la rue de solférino qui
est l'ancien siège du parti socialiste
et bien il a été revendu il a changé et
revendu un géant du parfum trois fois
plus cher qu'à trois ans et oui je suis
un peu agents immobiliers aussi ce matin
notre 1000 euros du mètre carré soit 125
millions d'euros que 100000 mans qu'on
dit bientôt vous avez vu que l'inserm 10
est déjà passé et donc si qui est
terrifiant c'est à quel point nous ne
sommes habitués à l'idée de la mort une
belle plus value pour le vendeur qui
avait donc racheté les lieux au ps fin
2017 pour 45 millions d'euros
le parti socialiste en difficulté
financière après une série d'échecs
électoraux avait été obligé de céder cet
hôtel particulier du 7e arrondissement
de paris je suis maintenant le quatrième
président américain à gérer la présence
militaire américaine en afghanistan de
républicains deux démocrates
je ne transmettrait pas cette
responsabilité à un cinquième
voici d'ailleurs le chef politique de
ces talibans en février dernier avec ce
négociateur américain
il signait un accord et promettait de
ramener la paix en afghanistan
l'heure est venue de mettre fin à la
plus longue guerre de l'amérique
il est temps que les troupes américaines
rentrent à la maison
le retrait des troupes étrangères les
deux pays seul face aux menaces